In this segment, we introduce
the subject of least
mean squares estimation.
But as a warm-up, we will
start with a very simple
special case.
Suppose that we have
some random variable
that we wish to estimate and
that we have the probability
distribution of this random
variable-- a probability
mass function if it's discrete
or a probability density
function if it's continuous.
As a concrete instance, suppose
that our random variable
is uniformly distributed
over a certain interval.
We would like to estimate
this random variable.
We're interested in
a point estimate.
However, we look at
the very special case
where there are no
observations available.
All that we have is this
probability distribution.
How do we estimate
this random variable?
Well, we can use the
rules that we have already
developed, for
example, the maximum
a posteriori probability
rule, what would it do?
In this case, since there
are no observations,
the posterior distribution of
Theta is the same as the prior.
There are no observations
that could change the prior.
So we need to find a point
at which this distribution is
highest.
Well, because this
distribution is flat,
the MAP rule does not
give us a unique answer.
Any value of theta inside
the interval from 4 to 10
would be an acceptable answer.
So any particular estimate in
this interval would be fine.
So this rule is not
particularly helpful.
How about a different estimator?
We have seen the conditional
expectation estimator.
Once more, in our case, since
we do not have any observations,
the conditional expectation is
the same as the expectation.
And for this
particular example, it
would give us the midpoint
of the distribution, namely
an estimate equal to 7.
Now, this rule was inconclusive.
This rule gave us a number.
How can we choose and
decide that one of these
is the right estimate?
We can do that if we introduce a
specific performance criterion.
What is it that we wish
from our estimators?
And the particular
criterion, the one
that will we be focusing on,
is the mean squared error.
If you come up with
a certain estimate,
you look at how far is your
estimate from the true value
that you're trying to estimate,
take the square of that,
and average it.
And this leads us
to a formulation
whereby we will try to find
an estimate theta hat that
minimizes this
mean squared error
over all possible estimates.
Let us now look at
this formulation
and see how we can solve it.
This is a function of a
single variable theta hat.
And we can try to minimize it
using conventional methods.
To carry out this
minimization, let
us first expand this
expectation into a sum of terms.
We have the expected
value of the square
of the random variable,
then a cross term minus 2
the expected value of
Theta times theta hat.
However, theta hat is a number
that we're trying to choose.
It's not random.
Therefore, we can pull it
outside the expectation.
And similarly, the last term,
the expected value of theta hat
squared is just theta
hat squared itself.
This is what we
want to minimize.
How do we minimize it?
We take the derivative
with respect to theta hat
and set it to 0.
And this gives us minus 2
the expected value of Theta
plus twice theta hat equal to 0.
And when we solve
this, we find is
that theta hat, the
optimal estimate
is equal to the
expected value of Theta.
So this is the answer to
our optimization problem.
The optimal estimate, according
to the least squares criterion,
is the expected value
of the random variable.
Now, it's interesting to
derive this result, also,
in a second way.
Since it is a quite important
and fundamental result,
let us see whether there is a
different way of establishing
it that stays closer to the
probabilistic world rather
than the calculus world.
So let us look at this
criterion that we have here.
The expected value of the
square of a random variable
is always equal to the variance
of that random variable
plus the expected value of
that random variable squared.
This is what we're
trying to minimize.
Now, theta hat is a constant.
The variance of a random
variable plus or minus
a constant is the
same as the variance
of that random variable.
And there is nothing that
we can do about this term.
So what we're trying
to do is, essentially,
just try to minimize this term
with respect to theta hat.
Now, here we have the
square of something.
The way to minimize this is to
try to make this quantity as
small as possible,
make it 0 if we can.
Well, we can make it 0 if we set
theta hat equal to the expected
value of Theta.
So this term here is minimized.
When theta hat is equal to
the expected value of Theta,
it is minimized because
this is a choice that
will make this term equal to 0.
So this was a second
derivation of why
this is the optimal
estimate of Theta.
Once we adopt this
particular estimate,
the mean squared
error is going to be
equal to this, because
this is our theta hat.
And, of course, we recognize
that this is the variance.
So the variance of Theta
is the least possible value
of the mean squared
error that we
can obtain using any
particular estimate.
And this is our
final conclusion.
And in the next segment, we
will exploit the conclusions
that we found here
and apply them
to a more general situation.